la liberté d'expression at elle ses
limites la question fait débat en france
et à l'international
en cause notamment les caricatures du
prophète mahomet republié par la presse
française est soutenu par emmanuel
macron lui même c'était le 21 octobre
dernier à lors de la cérémonie d'hommage
à samuel pâtit le professeur d'histoire
géographie assassiné parce qu'il a lui
même présenté ses caricatures alors d'un
cours sur la laïcité
nous défendrons la liberté que vous
enseignez si bien et nous porterons haut
à la laïcité
nous ne renoncerons pas aux caricatures
au dessin même si d'autres reculs des
propos qui ont suscité un véritable
tollé dans plusieurs pays musulmans et
les conséquences ne se sont pas fait
attendre
manifestation monstre effigies des
manuels macron brûlé le drapeau national
piétiner appel au boycott des produits
français et même vives réactions de
plusieurs personnalités politiques à
l'instar du président turc ou de
l'ancien premier ministre malaisien une
polémique sur les caricatures qui n'est
pas né d'hier
en 2006 le sujet attisait déjà les
tensions
jacques chirac à l'époque président de
la république préférait alors joué la
carte de l'apaisement sur la question
des caricatures et des réactions qu'elle
provoque dans le monde musulman
je rappelle que si la liberté
d'expression est un des fondements de la
république
celle ci repose également sur les
valeurs de tolérance et de respect de
toutes les croyances
tout ce qui peut blesser les convictions
d'autrui en particulier les convictions
religieuses doit être évité la liberté
d'expression doit s'exercer dans un
esprit de responsabilité
je condamne toutes les provocations
manifeste susceptible d'attiser
dangereusement les passions
ici à nice une question est sur toutes
les lèvres
aurait-on pu éviter l'attentât de la
basilique notre dame de l'assomption l
art publication des caricatures du
prophète mahomet et le discours d'
emmanuel macron sur la liberté
d'expression
ont-ils mis de l'huile sur le feu ici
les
avis sont mitigés la france est un pays
laïc on a le droit de dire ce qu'on veut
mais en même temps en même temps je suis
content la provocation religieuse
je suis contre qui est des caricatures
ou qu on caricaturise quoi que ce soit
la religion chrétienne juifs ou
musulmane parce que c'est quelque chose
de sacré j'ai tout le monde maintenant
les violons sont là et
ces personnes étaient préparés bien
avant que
monsieur mc ren ai parlé parce que je
pense pas qu'on puisse préparer quelque
chose comme ça en des jours aujourd'hui
on pense surtout aux familles des
victimes
mais il serait que l'ambiance générale
on peut pas savoir si on aurait pu
éviter ce genre de drame
c'est sûr que la proclamation des
caricatures saprissa peut-être et ça
peut être était une provocation mais bon
en france il ya la liberté d'expression
et ils vont la défendre jusqu'au bout
coup après l'attentât de la basilique
notre dame de l'assomption qui a coûté
la vie à trois personnes
l'heure est toujours au recueillement
ici à nice une cérémonie chez d'ailleurs
prévue ce dimanche à 18 heures pour
rendre un dernier hommage aux victimes
de l'attentât